hey guys can Rob's in here with a very
expensive GS news update the deal is
real Microsoft has bought minecraft
creators mojang for a cool 2.5 billion
dollars both parties confirm the news
via separate posts on mojang calm and
news Xbox calm but wait do you like to
play Minecraft on a non-microsoft device
well don't worry CMO jang in the studios
rather cryptically titled posts to fans
yes we're being bought by microsoft it
suggests that the deal will not result
in the deletion of minecraft games and
apps available on non-microsoft devices
there's no reason for the development
sales and support of the PC Mac xbox 360
xbox one ps3 ps4 Vita iOS and Android
versions of Minecraft to stop although
they conceded that of course Microsoft
can't make decisions for other companies
or predicted choices that they might
make in the future microsoft also chimed
in with words to similar effect Xbox
head honcho Phil Spencer explained that
whether you're playing on an xbox
whether you're playing on a Playstation
an iOS device our goal is to continue to
evolve and innovate with minecraft
across all those platforms whether or
not Sony will allow a Microsoft product
on its consoles however is a question
that's yet to be categorically answered
gamespot reached out to sony computer
entertainment europe last week when
rumors of the acquisition first began to
circulate at the time scee commented
that we cannot comment on any
acquisition however we can confirm that
we are very excited minecraft is now
available on ps3 and ps4 and coming to
PS Vita later this year gamespot
contacted sony again for additional
comment on the acquisition that is
official but did not hear back at time
of recording so make sure you check out
the full written news story on gamespot
com for the very latest updates so how
much money will land in not she's
already fairly cash Laden lap well the
minecraft creates her own seventy
percent of the company according to the
financial times so that stands to make
him 1.75 billion from the deal although
how much of this is in cash and how much
is in shares is unknown
now exactly how much of this song he
plans to spend on hurts though is yet to
be confirmed but if he does gamespot
smartest number ologist stuff calculated
that at 30 bucks each 1.75 billion
dollars equates to roughly fifty six
million 666666 fedora hats assuming he
reaches the average life expectancy in
Sweden of 81 in his remaining 50 years
of life that works out at 131 hats per
hour or a hat change roughly every 27
seconds for the rest of his days
regardless of how many hats he desert up
bang however notch won't be wearing them
as an employee of Mojang as along with
the chief executive kahramana and
co-founder of jacob poor sir he will be
leaving the company so would you make of
this story happy to see Microsoft at the
helm sad to see notches involvement in
the game come to an end or just confused
as to why I spent so much time
converting vast sums of money into hats
let me know in the comments down below
and for all your video game news keep it
on gamespot com